- [Morgan] Here's the first question.
What was Joey's three-word pickup line?
(beep)
- How you doin?
(bell rings)
(Kelly cheers)
(audience cheering)
(audience clapping)
Yeah!
(Amy laughing)
- [Morgan] All right calm
down girl, calm down.
- I know, I'm like Monica.
- [Morgan] I understand.
Question number two.
Monica was furious when Joey
got his head stuck in what?
- Oh.
(clock ticking)
- The turkey.
- I know that.
(bell rings)
- [Morgan] There it is.
(audience clapping)
- I knew that one.
- [Morgan] Turkey is correct.
It is now one to one.
- He was like, "I can't do anything."
- [Morgan] Question number three.
What was the name of Joey's character
on "Days of our Lives."
- Whoa!
(clock ticking)
- We were so close.
- Denied.
- That'd be Dr. Drake Ramoray.
(buzzer buzzing)
(bell rings)
- We new that one.
- That is correct.
- We've got to be quicker.
We've got to be quicker--
- All right, fine, fine.
- [Morgan] Let's get into it, here we go.
Question four.
Joey and Chandler had two pets,
what were they?
- Oh.
(clock ticking)
- Chicken and a duck.
(bell rings)
(Kelly cheers)
(audience cheering)
- That is correct.
- He didn't know (laughs).
- I did know.
- You did, oh (laughs).
I thought you were like,
oh no.
- He knows everything.
- Fact is, it was a chick
and a duck, not a chicken.
(Kelly laughing)
- That's true.
- All right that's fine, okay.
- God still favors our side.
(Amy laughing)
- [Morgan] Well, let's
find out what happens here?
Question five.
When the guys went on a ride along,
what did Joey protect from a gunshot.
- Oh.
(clock ticking)
- I didn't even get the full question.
(Amy chuckling)
- Meatball sandwich.
(buzzer buzzes)
(bell rings)
- That is correct, meatball sandwich.
- It's always a sandwich.
- It's my sandwich.
(Amy laughing)
- Okay, do we just lose.
- Now, the score I will say,
team Ahmatt you are winning
with three points, and team Kellamy
you have two..
- Oh, thank you.
- Ah.
- We've got it, we've got it.
- [Morgan] Here's our next question.
- Hold on, hold on, hold
on, hold on, hold on.
Have you seen the show?
- Yes, of course.
(audience laughing)
- He was in it, you're fine.
- It was a long time ago.
- Me too (laughs).
- [Matt] Tell me about
it, a long time ago, okay.
- [Morgan] I not only saw
the show, I created it.
Let's continue.
- Thank you.
(all laughing)
- [Kelly] You're welcome.
- Amazing.
- Question number six.
Phoebe tried to teach Joey
which foreign language.
- Oh, my Gosh!
(clock ticking)
(Amy screaming)
- French.
(bell rings)
- [Morgan] That is correct.
- I knocked my nail off.
(Amy laughing)
- Really.
- I knocked my nail off, I
was still trying to get there.
- [Morgan] Here's the next question.
Rachel's daughter became
attached to Hugsy,
Joey's bedtime what?
- Oh, my gosh.
- Bedtime pal.
- [Morgan] That.
(bell pings)
- He gets it before the
question's even asked.
- What I love most is the cyanide
that comes with victory.
- I want you to start asking
American Idol questions, right now.
(audience laughing)
I will slay (laughs).
- [Morgan] All right
here's the next question.
What luxury sports car
did Joey pretend to own.
- Porsche.
(bell rings)
Yeah!
- [Morgan] That is correct.
(audience cheering)
- I got you.
I got you.
Right in there.
- That was it.
- I was right at the bottom.
- [Morgan] And ladies and gentlemen.
Team Ahmatt has won.
- Thanks to you man.
- [Kelly] Great job.
(Kelly and Amy mumbling)
- [Morgan] Congratulations
because you just won
all the men in the audience
a Vita one-cup coffee brewer
and coffee, tea.
But, since I created the
universe and call the shots,
the entire audience gets the prize.
(all cheering)